[Music]
yeah thank God but I'm gonna do it
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings
and today we're joined by Halle Berry
she's one of the most successful
actresses in Hollywood with a storied
career in film that spans more than 25
years we can catch her starring
alongside Keanu Reeves and John wick 3
which is currently in theaters and
number one at the box office
Halle Berry welcome to the show thank
you really happy to be here how are you
at spicy food do you crank it I normally
do but now I'm a little scared but I
normally do I'm always get the spiciest
of the spicy wherever I am so well you
came to the right place well I came here
for dinner I was laying on I gotta eat I
want to come here and I'm gonna have my
dinner
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
oh god this looks like a really hot one
you trying to fool me lightwork oh yeah
just like work we got those these are
good so there's been a lot of press
around the blood sweat and tears that
went into making John wick three whether
it's stories about broken ribs or these
viral videos of you tactical training
and Simi Valley can you give us one
Hollywood trade secret when it comes to
the art of the fight scene we really do
it you know that's the way I think
what's great about John wick world all
right that's all right it happens on
this show there's like um constant
contact you know but you do it in a very
controlled way but the contact is really
real if you hit someone you're really
hitting someone if you throw someone
you're really throwing someone so it's
as real as you can get without really
hurting each other how does the
physicality of this film compared to
some of the action films that you've
done in the past I know that for Die
Another Day it you caught some grenade
shrapnel me I I did but honestly the
other ones felt like baby games compared
to this really I tell you the truth yeah
I never worked harder and this one you
know I broke three ribs in my training
process it was on another level of hard
and challenging and taxing and I learned
so many new things martial arts and
weaponry and dog training I mean it was
amazing
[Music]
so I want to stay on the topic of John
because I know that in addition to the
martial arts training and the weapons
training that you also had to commit so
much time to these hyper-intelligent
Belgian Malinois hounds yeah well to
take any of that dog training home to
the labradoodles I did actually I
learned through this experience any dog
can be trained I mean if you have a
little you know chihuahua okay maybe
they're not going to hurt anybody but
they can't be taught to attack you know
what I mean so I've just recently taught
my dogs to sit by the front door and you
know sit I had attention waiting for me
to come in them and if I say take it
they will take whoever's coming through
the door they're on guard he'll attack
them hot ones creator Christian Berger
he has this dog who is very very sweet
he's a mix Irish setter
golden retriever but he is semi poorly
behaved so on the topic of dog training
can I show you just a few pics of him
doing Ruggles things and if you have any
pro tips for how we can turn around this
behavior we'd really get this for
example so here's Ruggles Oh Ruggles is
his name tearing up the mail Runkles is
a hot damn mess oh no Ruggles see
Ruggles couldn't live in my house do you
have any advice Brad to turn around a
dog that expresses his separation
anxiety this way well you need some
bitter apple bitter first thing that's
what you use to stop them from chewing
and barking and it looks like Ruggles
here likes to chew up [ __ ] like you just
he's a chewer noted here he is longing
for a cake with his own face on do you
have any advice for how to keep a dog
from begging for table scraps I'm still
struggling with the eating because some
dogs just have this trigger one of my
dogs is like that and he just he eats it
up yeah alright well we'll figure this
one out together
finally here's Ruggles chewing on a do
not cross which is just general
anti-establishment gonna make jail he's
gonna go to jail I know he's going right
to the pound if he keeps this up what I
learned from Andrew Simpson was that all
dog training has to be done with love so
it should all be done gently
and with love reinforcement yes yes
that's what I know Shaquanda oh my girl
Shaquanda mm-hmm yep this is like some
neighborhood sauce yeah so you've worked
consistently in the movie business and
superior and Spike Lee's jungle fever in
1991 which is impressive in its own
right but I'm curious how you think the
moviemaking process has changed over
that time and specifically do you feel
like the way that movies are made is
changing now that more and more people
aren't consuming them that traditional
theatre experience I've seen it changed
dramatically and I've had to you know
evolve with the evolution of moviemaking
and find a way to sort of fit into this
new frontier because that's really I
think what it is but at the end of the
day I'm all for people being able to
watch it how they want to how they want
to watch it I think what the goal is is
to get people to actually watch the art
that we create and if we make it easier
for them to consume it in ways that are
more comfortable for them I think that
should be that should be the goal well
we have to evolve this seems relevant to
ask while you're eating scorching out
chicken wings on YouTube but how did
appearing on a talk show in 1999 how is
that different than in 2019 I think
what's different is now we and like you
know when I was the other day I had to
eat turkey balls right your honor all
your guts failure yeah back then nobody
was eating turkey balls at least not out
in the open but we've evolved into
people I think that are more voyeuristic
we want to see what's real we want to
see our celebrities or our idols or our
actors or our athletes or we want to see
them do real [ __ ] real stuff you know we
want to be closer to them and I'm not
actually like that that's where we're
going it's more of a connection
[Music]
this one's kind of sweet mm-hmm so far
I'm doing okay you're doing really good
okay nothing's got me yet but these down
here look super red yeah there's
something ominous about all that I think
it's gonna get bad down there this is
just the warmup mm-hmm so whenever we
get a chance we love to ask our
celebrity guests what it's like to be
name-checked and rap lyrics and I'm
gonna go out on a limb and say that
Halle Berry is probably the most
referenced actress in the history of
hip-hop everyone from biggie to Missy
Elliott to Drake do you have a favorite
Halle Berry reference no you know why I
think of these references like my
children in a way there's no way I could
pick one I love all these artists I'm
always flattered when any one of them
include me and that they still remember
me know who I am
so to pick one would be like picking
like my daughter over myself you know I
love them all this one on paper is
amazing I don't know what it means but
maybe you do it's from nas off it's mine
silk shirts on my chest show what a
flirt Halle Berry blew a kiss at the
Barbra Streisand concert did you ever go
to a Barbra Streisand concert and see
NAS I don't think I've ever been lucky
enough to go to one it was an impostor
if he was there it was a Halle Berry boy
it was a doppelganger yeah one more for
you from Kanye West off the new workout
plan have you heard this one what's
scary to me is honey make girls look
like Halle Berry to me see that's the
great thing about rap sometimes you
don't know what the hell they're saying
you know you don't really understand it
right
I guess he's saying yeah honey makes I
know people get drunk and they think
they look like Halle Berry right
that's exactly all right Kanye well I'm
gonna take that I'm gonna accept that
[Music]
Oh No there's no scallion this is going
to be muy muy delicioso
[Music]
and I thought you said you do everything
I do I'm right with you right with you
all right with you check my math I mean
I don't want to look like a pig on the
show no people will respect this you're
cleaning the wings like a champion right
now
let's see if you can keep it going but
right now these red ones look a little
scary
all right Halle Berry a recurring
segment on our show called explain that
grand where we do a deep dive and I
guess Instagram pull interesting
pictures that need more context and with
Halle Berry we have a theme we've gone
deep into the Getty archives to pull
some classic Halle Berry throw backs so
I'll just show you the picture okay oh
don't you worry do you remember how you
celebrated your Oscar win no I was
inebriated remember any of it done very
shortly after I got that statue I became
inebriated to the point that I the whole
night is awash do you remember anything
about Elton John's party that I think I
was there I must have been because look
we're together I'm throwing out a first
pitch at a Cubs game next month do you
have any advice because I'm bizarrely
nervous about it do some practicing you
don't want to embarrass yourself totally
and just get it near the plate because
those bad first pitches I feel like they
follow you forever do you you won't
survive that you won't survive a bad
first pitch
Oh Detroit Hellfire now we're getting
serious mm-hmm
damaged product mm-hmm we're in the back
half so you once made an interesting
point to vote that you're more likely to
get compliments from people on the
street for BAPS than say even your
Academy Award winning performance and
monsters ball have you ever been
surprised by the types of validation
that are most important to you yeah yes
yes and no you know I think when I when
people run up and they love that I
absolutely know why do I think that's
one of my best performances maybe not
but I know why for the community and for
my culture like what that means to us as
a people and as women and so I get why
that sort of be loved by a certain group
of people and that means a lot to me
always
what's the Halle Berry film project that
people seem most interested in when they
approach on the street believe it or not
so how many people come up and they say
I don't care what anybody says Halle
Berry I love Catwoman okay well what did
they say well they say it sucked but it
really didn't suck really it didn't you
were good I mean the movie might have
sucked but you were good so we have this
whole dialogue about the movie and then
we always have a good laugh about it and
then they say okay now do Catwoman too
and I'm like no probably not in this
life but you're asleep thank you
this is the red one Oh where's this the
bomb or not the next one is the bomb oh
this is not the bomb
this is Wilshire Chile firm okay I'm
going right with ya just turn it up a
notch yeah take off but I'm gonna do it
so no profile back in 1999 you were
described as an avid web surfer but I
know the Internet has become a
significantly more precarious place now
especially for somebody who's super
famous do you still have that web
addiction or do you find yourself going
down the rabbit holes fewer and fewer
these days I do have this addiction and
it's a problem and I think like
everybody we have to find ways to not
get into that addiction because I don't
want to teach my kids that so it's very
hard to say don't just spend mindless
hours going down the rabbit hole and
then my kids see me doing it so I have a
really good reason to like battle it
when you see USA this has like after
kick yeah right we have reached a point
in the show where we are just full speed
ahead okay do this one okay cuz like
there's after like all this Delilah is
now there's a lingering cumulative it is
right when you see USA Today online
articles with actual headlines like
Halle Berry looks like a late-night
snack in a steamy braless picture does
it make you want to delete Instagram
forever is that just a sign that the
social media strategy is working
you know it's my footprint for life you
know it never goes away once you put it
out there so I try to be thoughtful I
know we already went through the
throwbacks but I do want to show you one
more do you remember the sorts of IT
questions that you are asking see I was
a pioneer you were I was doing this
before we were doing this exactly right
exactly that's from the Hollywood yeah
the original launch hmm why were you so
into the internet early on what did you
see I knew that
says where we were going to evolve to I
really knew and I knew that people like
me would be able to use this forum and
we'd be able to have our own voice
handle our own PR and have a real
one-on-one connection like I used to
have contests wide fly fans out and I
would take them on shopping sprees that
we go to a spa together or whatever I
just knew this was going to be the great
connector between us and not only the
world but to our you know to our fans
for the people that provide us the right
to do exactly what we love okay we're
moving on we are moving on to da bomb oh
okay let's go let's go for it
[Music]
yeah it's the work well and it's also
the nasty oh yeah it's not even good
though not a lot of positives with this
not with this one it's just hot and
bitter what I'm gonna do it
okay then I'm doing it I will not be
defeated oh [ __ ] top down yeah and you
want to talk about the cumulative but
yet look at you nasty though we are
cleaning bones here do not get the bomb
the bomb you do not want to get the bomb
you don't go through all that it should
at least be good so before your career
in Hollywood I know that your first
runner-up and Miss USA and this might
come as a shock to you and everyone
watching right now but my girlfriend was
actually Miss California in 2016 and I
have become obsessed with pageants over
the last year yeah do you feel heat I
think I singed my eyebrows with that
that was a hot work we did did you ever
have to use butt glue you know what [ __ ]
butt glue no oh
what is butt glue so [ __ ] glue
Buckley it keeps you from having a
wedgie so if you have that like butt
glue it'll just keep everything straight
for you I didn't have any butt glue no
bug glue oh do you remember your
interview question and what you did to
prepare for it I don't remember the
enemy a question and you just got a hope
that you can you know that your mind is
working and you can actually construct
and answer that what's good training for
what I do now that's like sitting here
with you right now with my mouth fire
trying to talk looking back on your
beauty pageant career what's the most
savage thing you've ever seen someone do
to try to get a competitive edge oh I
saw and this is real story it's just in
the Miss World pageant a girl cut the
heel off another girl shoe so and she
stuck it back on but not really glued so
the girl put the shoes on and went
walking and got about four steps and her
heels broke off it's a call he's real
scared they can't pick it I don't know
how they are now but back in my day it
was vicious no I know he's got to lock
up that garment bag with a with a
padlock cause it just might be gone
exactly
okay let's go what is this
we are here at does that say chocolate
chocolate player play leg okay can't
read it can't see
[Music]
this is me this is me I'm here so you're
telling me there's no you unfair okay
you're going I'm going
or ello died and is wing'd right now
before I lose and we might we might and
we might we're on our way
[Music]
so you've accomplished so much in the
last 25 years that it would be
impossible to touch every base here just
over ten chicken wings but we'll try to
tie up a few loose ends here on the
chocolate plague between x-men James
Bond and John wick which franchise has
the most intense fans of what oh my god
the fans are different they're all
different but if that way
the Bond fans I think are nothing like
that the x-men fans and the John wick
fans are just like they're
thrill-seekers they are gentle and
drunky ease they're like another kind of
fan I think they all have really solid
really solid important fan bases were
you aware that the lawsuit were you
aware that the Los Angeles Rams have a
play called Halle Berry your lives on
fire whoa okay was a question did you
know that the Los Angeles Rams have a
play called Halle Berry I learned that
this year yeah talked about that I just
wanted to know what that was was that a
good thing is that like let's do that
really cool play or is that let's do
that like well it's cool cuz like when I
watched the game Jared Goff the
quarterback sometimes they'll just be
he'll be looking at the defense then
I'll just be like Halle Berry Halle
Berry you know and then everybody runs
around and goes into a different
position and then they run a play and
they went to the Super Bowl so you know
they have a good place so I'm gonna take
it as a good play what do you think was
your greatest haircut of all time the
greatest haircut
is that for what's about to happen
[Music]
you can put extra sauce on this one
mm-hmm
this is the last dab we call it the last
stab because it's tradition around here
to put a little extra on the last wing
you don't have to if you don't want to
all you did so yeah I know I knew I
could see that coming
Oh guys well you know what you're
competitive I'm compelled to go with a
Halle Berry Deb you know that's will
call from here on out it was so stupid
why are we doing this like I have sweat
dripping from my boob
[Music]
okay Halle Berry here we are at our
spicy wing finish line and I know that
you have a trophy case that's packed
from your Oscar to your Emmy to your
Golden Globe and a couple of SAG Awards
but I think that you're gonna have to
make some room on that mantle because we
would like to present you with the hot
ones trophy of excellence it is the
highest honor that we have ever bestowed
to a guest on the show and it's for you
coming in here clean and wings go and
bite for bite whether it takes us out or
not is there anyone that you would like
to think I must make my damn self on
this one because I did it nobody helped
me so much I'm tired me either my damn
stuff sometimes you just have to put the
world on your shoulders and look at you
Halle Berry ten chicken wings up ten
chicken wings down and I think that
we're both better people for it and now
there's nothing left to do but roll out
the red carpet for you my friend
this camera this camera or this camera
let the people know what you have going
on in your life
[Music]
I got nothing okay John wick right now
thank you how was dinner
it was really good we've got en fuego
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is Sean Evans as a reminder that
Father's Day is just around the corner
so with that in mind I want to tell you
a story about the first time that I ever
ate something spicy so I was a little
kid watching the Bears game with my dad
when I took it tortilla chip dipped into
the salsa took a bite and was
immediately set on fire I looked at my
dad and a panic and I said do we have
mild and he looked at me and he said not
in my house there a seed was planted and
eventually I became a fully grown adult
with a hot wing talk show dad's to the
best so think about dad this Father's
Day and think about picking them up a
hot one subscription box heat nest calm
heat nest calm to order the hot one
subscription box it's the gift that
keeps on giving
literally because it just comes every
single month one of those is good right